September 9, 2015 I was standing outside the
Hyatt Hotel in Midtown Manhattan, planning
on getting a car heading to the US Open.
I do some corporate appearances and sponsor
visits and things like that.
I didn't think much of it.
I looked up while I was waiting for the car
and saw someone running towards me, and as
he got to me I was smiling thinking this was
some sort of friendly encounter—a fan or
someone that was just a long lost friend or
something—but he quickly dispelled that
myth in my head and put me on the ground and
slammed me to the ground and had his knee
in my back and cuffed me and told me to not
say a word and just listen to whatever he
had to say.
So I did.
I complied.
I had seen everything in the news about noncompliance
or perceived noncompliance of anyone in custody
of the police so I stood up and did what he
said.
And they said it was just a case of mistaken
identity, but it was clearly, in my mind,
excessive, and it didn't need to be handled
that way when there were five officers on
the scene and could have easily just asked
me for my identification and moved on and
not had any sort of an incident.
As it was happening I was pretty much in shock.
I try to think of myself as pretty calm, cool
and collected, and I didn't know what to do
and what to say, how to act—because I hadn't
been put in cuffs like that before, I didn't
know how else to get my point across because
they weren't listening.
I was trying to let them know that my US Open
credential was in my back pocket.
“I’m not someone that—whatever it is
you're looking for, for whatever kind of criminal
you're looking for, it has nothing to do with
me, it's not me.”
They weren't hearing it.
They didn't want to hear anything about it.
They were in power; they were in control,
and let me know that.
So going through it I was embarrassed, I felt
extremely vulnerable, because they had me
cuffed and I didn't know what for, and I didn't
know what they were planning on doing.
So, the blue wall of silence, from what I
understand it, is when any officer does something
wrong, inappropriate, the rest of the officers
are going to be silent.
They're not going to mention it, they're not
going to go against him and turn them into
internal affairs or turn them into anyone
else, they're going to stick with him and
that's almost like a fraternity, a brotherhood.
And it's something that is hopefully outdated
and was prevalent supposedly back in the '70s,
'80s, '90s.
A lot of the officers I speak to now say that
it's a thing of the past, that it's not happening,
but in my case it seems like it happened,
because there are five officers that all witnessed
what happened, or four that witnessed what
happened, one was that was the instigator,
and none of them filed a report.
Any of them could have filed a report and
said, “This is what happened on this day,
this was inappropriate,” but none of them
did.
So the first time the NYPD made a statement
it was that they were investigating whether
excessive force was used, and that I wasn't
even in handcuffs, and the whole encounter
took less than just a couple of minutes.
And when I saw that and couldn't believe that
that was the story they were going to go with,
I didn't even know at that time that there
was a videotape.
There was surveillance footage that showed
what actually happened, and it was just infuriating
to see that because I knew that if there wasn't
that video they could get away with that,
they could say that and they could have four
or five officers say the same thing “No,
nothing happened,” and move on, and I was
very much afraid that that was going to be
the case.
Even as much as I feel like I'm credible—I
have no reason to lie or to make up a story—I
feel like the general public would listen
to five cops that are on the scene that would
say one thing even if it's contradictory to
what I say actually happened.
After I got back from the US Open is when
I realized that there was a video, and as
soon as I spoke to the head of security at
the Grand Hyatt he said, "Well, I saw that
too and we have the timestamp on here, and
it was for 15 minutes so we know how long
you were in cuffs for, we have them leading
you away in cuffs, we have all of that."
So I was very thankful to him for helping
me and for making sure that tape stayed safe,
because I think that's what helped the truth
get out and helped people realize that I wasn't
just making this up or that what they initially
said was far from the truth.
And I don't blame the ones that are the higher-ups,
the powers that be because they may have heard
that story from the officers that were on
the scene, and you would expect them to believe
them to tell the truth.
And without that video there was no way for
them to know that, so they had no reason to
not believe them.
I just think it's sad that that would be how
those police officers that saw it on the scene
would then report that to their superior officers.
It was something where I wanted to make sure
that the police officers that aren't doing
the job the right way don't take away from
the police officers that are doing the job
the right way, and the ones that are so-called
bad apples are held accountable.
And that's when I decided I wanted to make
that something I was going to write about,
something I was going to talk about and speak
on, the fact that it just can't keep happening.
Police departments in these cases, in my opinion,
would be better off with transparency, with
letting a lot of people know, letting the
public know exactly what happened and finding
out from the rest of the officers what really
happened.
And I think so many officers I've spoken to
since that time really feel like that whole
blue wall of silence is not a real thing,
that they're not all sticking up for each
other, but it seems in this case they did.
And if that is just maybe optimism from other
police officers and police departments, I
hope that it's going in that direction, that
there will stop being the whole “blue wall
of silence” that they won’t just stick
up for each other no matter what's right or
wrong as opposed to just sticking up for what
is right for what actually happened for the
truth.
And as far as police reform across the country—I
just hope for more transparency all across
the country.
And the accountability is what matters to
me, because I truly believe that the majority,
over 95 percent of the police officers are
acting in an honorable dignified way and they
deserve to be called heroes, but the ones
that aren't are really eroding the trust.
The ones that are doing the wrong things are
making it so that people like myself, anyone
that's been in any sort of encounter like
this may lose some of their trust for any
police officer, and that's not fair to the
ones that are doing the job the right way
that deserve our trust that we should look
to for support to keep us safe, to keep our
communities safe.
And when the ones that aren't doing it that
way, the ones that are using the badge as
a shield to protect them as a way to continue
being a bully or anything else they're using
it for—those are the ones that should not
be protected by the unions, by any sort of
system that is going to just protect—“once
you get a badge you're protected”—I think
that shouldn't be the case, you need to be
accountable no matter what your job is.
You're a human being and you need to be held
accountable for your actions, especially when
you're allowed to make life or death situations
with the people you interact with.
And if someone is making a life or death situation
with my life I would like them to be trained
properly, I would like them to feel comfortable
in every situation, I would like them to not
feel scared in any situation, and I'd like
to know that they are doing so with honor
and with respect for my life and for the lives
of everyone in their community.